welcome to another edition of scholastic  checkmates I am your host 1998 Missouri  scholastic state champion Michael comer  so this was my first game I ever played  I'm doing pretty good as black as you  see and here goes white he's coming down  he's gonna attack my bishop and my pawn  so what do I do  guess what Chuck Merritt buddy all right  and that's how I became the guy I am  today but I wasn't always that good I  guess  because just seven weeks later I had a  pretty similar position except this time  I am playing black and I'm like hey I  think I'm gonna attack  here's c2 pawn and of course the most  elementary checkmate the weakest square  inch s f7 you got to protect the square  checkmate so you live and learn right